[Musique]
leur rempart majestueux trône toujours
sur les plaines d'andalousie la région
du sud de l'espagne est celle où l'on
dénombre le plus de château environ 2500
en haut des collines ou au creux des
vallées de style arabo hispanique ou
gothique
le moindre point est vraiment
spectaculaire
faut vraiment y aller c'est magique
comme en voyage dans le temps un voyage
qui nous emmène tout droit au moyen âge
ça c'est le donjon le plus haut
d'espagne 47 mètres de haut
plus précisément à l'époque de la
reconquête par les rois catholiques des
territoires occupés par les musulmans
l'aragon la reconquête de l'espagne est
allée du nord vers le sud et c'est en
andalousie que les musulmans ont le plus
résistant les frontières ont bougé
lentement il fallait défendre chaque
territoire conquis c'est pour ça qu'on a
construit beaucoup de châteaux dans la
région construit dans au moins deux
tonnes à castellon
des citadelles qui pour beaucoup sont
aujourd'hui à vendre et attire des
investisseurs étrangers
karine bar qui est une française
spécialisée dans la vente de ces 2 meur
hors du commun elle nous ouvre les
portes de ce château d'inspiration arabe
à une demi-heure de séville j'ai
beaucoup de français les personnes qui
en fait ont envie d'avoir eu un bien qui
est vraiment exceptionnel et ou au
soleil on peut avoir la semaine sainte
en ahl à la feria c'est tout un tas de
choses qui quand vous veut déménager ici
en fait vous épousez aussi toute une
culture aujourd'hui elle a rendez vous
avec une potentielle acheteuse normande
bonjour âge qui a préféré ne pas faire
le déplacement en pleine pandémie
coronavirus tour du propriétaire en
appel vidéo donc sur la gauche on va
voir à un petit loft donc c'est une
petite maison qu'est la partie la plus
ancienne de la propriété 2300 mètres
carrés habitables tout de même ça
deviendrait un an de toute aide
et
en plus de ça vous avez des grandes
salles en parallèle vous pouvez faire
des animations style un mariage un
baptême ce genre de chance prix estimé
du château entre 2 et 5 millions d'euros
à une centaine de km plus au sud nous
avons rendez vous avec une autre
française
pourrait faire ses vrais aménager un peu
cette zone magali et architecte de
formation et avec son mari elle a
dessiné et fait construire son propre
palais andalou
une dizaine d'années c'était simplement
un grand champ de blé il n'y avait pas
un arbre rien et j'ai connu cette région
et je suis à tomber amoureuse
complètement et j'ai dit c'est là que je
vais faire ce projet qui me tient à
coeur et on est heureux c'est vrai quand
on se balade ici et qu'on qu'on se
promène dans ce lieu on ce dernier on
est arrivés un peu moins d'un million
d'euros pour faire sortir de terre ses
murs blancs et autres typique de la
région l'endroit est à présent un hôtel
où toutes les chambres convergent vers
le traditionnel patio
toujours normalement avec le point d'eau
la petite fontaine centrale et bien sûr
cette végétation très présente les
bougainvilliers et ça donne cette
couleur chatoyante extraordinaire
la bâtisse est aujourd'hui mise en vente
magali espère acquérir une demeure
encore un peu plus grande pour
accueillir plus de monde et ce n'est pas
l'inspiration qui manque dans la région
à almodovar del rio le créneau des
propriétaires est clair replonger les
voyageurs à commencer par les plus
petits au moyen-âge
je vous fais ici et maintenant chevalier
d'honneur
et ça marche 80 mille visiteurs annuels
et une série télé mondialement connu
tourné sur ses remparts
nous a vraiment mis sous le feu des
projecteurs c'est une fierté pour moi
parce que le château de mon petit
village est maintenant connue comme la
forteresse de au jardin dans la série
une aubaine pour l'andalousie qui a
entrepris de restaurer bon nombre de ces
châteaux avec l'objectif de séduire bien
au delà de ces plages grâce aux vestiges
de son histoire millénaire